guardians  of the galaxy  you misread our intentions no you've  made them pretty clear  sometimes sacrifices  i had the check  quill kill  grand unifier  breaker right  first let me just say it's really cool  that you've heard of us right guys  and it's cool that you didn't try to  kill us just then especially with your  two pals right there it could have  totally ripped us apart the moment you  walked in which we obviously  all appreciate  but also  we've kind of got a few questions like  you came here seeking truth  rejoice  the matriarch wishes to share it with  you  okay that is really not cool  the matriarch awaits  [Music]  [Applause]  wow  [Music]  [Applause]